[Música]
salud en directo América de Francia 24 y
más Romero sala está con nosotros en el
estudio mar vamos a hablar de Brasil
porque el presidente ayerbe el sonaro
opta como ya lo sabemos a la reelección
y su manejo de la pandemia fue muy
controvertida Hola Raúl Así es no
digamos que podemos decir que raya e
incluso en el negacionismo Aunque nunca
dijo que el Kobe 19 no existiera que
fuera un evento planeado pero su uso
formas de manejar la pandemia fueron
verdaderamente controvertidas no algunos
ejemplos esto es cuando él estaba
contagiado en este momento positivo por
covid 19 en julio de 2020 y salió a
saludar a algunos de sus seguidores a
pesar eso de tener un resultado positivo
en ese momento cuando además se
recomendaba el aislamiento más absoluto
para las personas que vieran positivo no
siempre rechazó en general tomar medidas
de distanciamiento social de usar
tapabocas en general también también
defendió tratamientos que están
demostrados que no funcionan contra el
covid 19 como la hidrocloroquina y
menoscabo la importancia de la pandemia
en en varias ocasiones todo esto de
hecho le valió una investigación en el
senado por crímenes de humanidad y
también un desfile de ministros de salud
que fueron cambiando a lo largo de la
pandemia Pero bueno Vamos a repasar
también algunas de sus declaraciones más
polémicas a lo largo de estos años de
pandemia
está la cuestión del coronavirus que
creo que está haciendo sobredimensionada
después de La puñalada no me va a tumbar
una gripita
quien no quiere tomar cloroquina que no
lo haga pero no se lo prohíban a la
gente contagiada que lo quiere hacer
después de una recomendación médica
no me voy a vacunar es mi derecho ante
todo es tomar Qué consecuencias tuvo
esta gestión devolucionar pues
definitivamente Brasil es uno de los
países con más casos y más a muertes por
covite 19 Aunque bueno proporcionalmente
con la población no tanto ahora
rebasaremos las cifras en general
sabemos que la pandemia golpeó duro a
todo el mundo no Incluso en países muy
preparados hubo verdaderas tragedias
pero digamos que tuvo ese punto extra de
tener mordes desbordadas hospitales
también los cementerios no familias
destrozadas y tener un presidente además
que parecía no ver esa esa realidad yo
recuerdo por ejemplo las trajidades que
sucedieron en manaos en la amazonía no
donde la falta de oxígeno hacía que las
personas no pudieran recibir tratamiento
contra el 19 personas que Podrían haber
quizás pues salido delante de la
enfermedad y terminaron apareciendo Pero
bueno vamos a las cifras en total en el
país a día de hoy Son más de 30 Casi 35
millones perdón de personas que se han
contagiado de covid 19 eso respecto a la
población son unas 162.000 por millones
de habitantes no es la más alta de
América Latina pero es de las más altas
en cuanto a las muertes
687.962 personas han perdido la vida por
el covid 19 en el país esos son 3.200
también por millón de habitantes después
de Perú en la región es la tasa de
mortalidad más alta no pero no es solo
eso también había un estudio publicado
recientemente la revista han hecho
Michael elogy que decía que más allá de
las cifras en el propio país Brasil
también había sido un país super
contagiador en la región uno de los
países que más casos de cobit había
exportado la Pues el lugar principal
donde los exportó el 65% Sudamérica
también a otras regiones del mundo en
menor medida pero digamos eso que Brasil
fue un centro desde donde salieron
muchos contagios y también agravaron así
pues la situación en el resto de la
región Marc influirá lo que ha pasado
durante la pandemia de covid 19 en estas
elecciones del domingo pues lo hemos
hablado algunas veces y hay un poco de
opiniones distintas no algunos dicen que
sí definitivamente que la pandemia ha
sido un motivo de descrédito para
bolsonar otros dicen que hay una cierta
Amnesia pereza de hablar no de la
pandemia y que además hay unos problemas
de economía que podrían opacar la
gestión de bolsonaro al frente del
gobierno brasileño en estos momentos de
crisis sanitaria sin embargo
verdaderamente sí ha llegado lejos la
gestión o la falta de gestión digamos de
bolsonaros respecto a la pandemia y
vamos a poner un ejemplo que es una
editorial publicada esta semana por la
revista natur una de las revistas más
prestigiosas pues del mundo en términos
de ciencia y de salud también en el que
básicamente critican y se dedican a
decir que bolsonaro ha desmantelado ha
destrozado cualquier tipo de política
basada en la evidencia científica No eso
y que además los votantes de Brasil
tienen una valiosa oportunidad para
empezar a reconstruir lo que bolsonaro
ha demolido y que si pues logra cuatro
años más el daño podría ser irreparable
reconoce que Lula no es un candidato
perfecto pero digamos que se posicionan
muy claramente en contra de bolsionar
una revista científica de las más
prestigiosas del mundo es decir hasta
aquí ha llegado las críticas que ha
recibido ahora amar habremos en las
propuestas de los candidatos respecto a
la salud pues tengo que decir que no son
tan claras Y no tan son tan concretas y
quizás por eso también nos muestra que
el tema pandemia quizás no es lo más
está pesando en este momento Aunque
Debería Debería hacerlo no vamos a
empezar por el programa electoral de
Lula da Silva Menciona por ejemplo
específicamente reimpulsar la campaña de
vacunación contra el 19 también
fortalecer el sistema único de salud
como le llaman el susno que es el
sistema Público de salud brasileño y
quieres regresar algunos de los
programas que él ya impulsó cuando ya
era presidente por ejemplo maíz médicos
que es un programa de cooperación con
los médicos cubanos Y con la oeps y
también farmacia popular unos programas
que servían para hacer más accesibles
medicamentos a la población general que
bolsonaro por ejemplo recortó en su
momento habla también de innovación a
tecnológica y social para combatir el
cambio climático y las amenazas de salud
pública y menciona el derecho al acceso
a la salud de mujeres y población lgt
para que nos hagamos una idea de los
trazos generales en cuanto a bolsonaro
En cambio no por su parte habla de
disminuir la presión sobre la atención
sanitaria intentando que estas personas
haciendo hablando de no por ejemplo con
programas de nutricionistas que hagan
que las personas estén en un mejor
estado de salud y no tengan que ir al
médico también habla de que la población
va a envejecer hace énfasis en eso y que
el sistema de salud debe estar preparado
para el futuro que llega también a
recalca el prono en un programa de
atención oncológica no basado en
expandir digamos del acceso a la
asistencia en este enfermedad reforzar
también la salud digital que vimos
durante la pandemia que fue una de las
claves para atender a las personas y por
supuesto un poco en su línea económica
de alianzas público privadas entre los
sectores de la salud públicos de los
sectores de la salud privadas de nuevo
trazos generales pero más o menos Esto
es lo que ponen sobre la mesa mar como
siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información de salud Muchas gracias a ti
Raúl